the March edition of Popular Mechanics
reported that the weather of the
previous year was strange warm cities
baked under the hot sun and crops wilted
as Farmers lost a million dollars a day
the good old-fashioned winters of Years
Gone by with 15-foot snowdrifts and
Lasting six months were a thing of the
past the author explained to the
audience that human emissions of carbon
dioxide were causing the planet to warm
this may sound familiar the kind of
reporting we hear all the time now but
this Edition wasn't published in 2022 it
was published in 1912.
foreign
[Music]
for many people climate change as a
topic seemed to appear in 2006 with
former American vice president Al Gore
and his documentary and inconvenience
truth and while this was certainly when
it burst into the mainstream for many
people it was only a late chapter of a
scientific story that stretched back
centuries Gore is not an insignificant
player in this story but is by no means
the main character Albert Arnold Gore Jr
enrolled in Harvard College in 1965.
during his senior year there he took a
class taught by a scientist named Roger
Ravel who showed his class some
intriguing data from a recent experiment
Revel was a giant I mean that literally
he was six foot four with a booming
voice but also scientifically he was
instrumental in the creation of the
international geophysical year of 1957
was scientific Project Lead on the study
of nuclear detonations on Bikini Atoll
and developed the Scripps oceanographic
Institute in California from having a
single research vessel to having a fleet
bigger than many countries navies he
became a huge deal but started out as a
humble PhD student at UC Berkeley in the
1930s researching how carbon dioxide or
CO2 was absorbed by the world's oceans
the rate of this absorption would turn
out to be one of the most significant in
the history of Science and revel would
be the key to its calculation why was it
so important because it determined how
much CO2 was present in the Earth's
atmosphere
in the late 18th century Scholars were
starting to realize that what we call
Air was actually comprised of multiple
gases notably oxygen and nitrogen both
discovered in the 1770s another was
carbonic acid gas what we would Now call
carbon dioxide it was first isolated and
described a little earlier in 1757 by
Joseph black a Scottish physicist and
chemist working in Glasgow black was
quite the researcher he discovered the
element magnesium as well as the concept
of latent heat the energy required to
change the phase of a substance but
apart from discovering it black didn't
learn much about carbon dioxide mostly
that it immediately extinguished Flames
that were immersed in the gas its most
relevant property would be described
almost exactly 100 years after its
Discovery but before talking about that
we need to take a brief diversion
[Music]
Jean-Baptiste Joseph Fourier was an
interesting character he obsessed with
heat he actually believed that he had
life-giving properties something he
picked up when he was forced by Napoleon
himself to accompany him on the French
invasion of scorching heart Egypt in
1798. several Adventures later Fourier
eventually found himself back in Paris
and was able to resume his passion
researching thermodynamics describing
mathematically how heat flows between
objects and changes their temperatures
in 1822 he published a seminal book
called The analytical theory of heat
which laid the foundations of several
key modern scientific Concepts including
Fourier transforms and the general
equation for how heat flows through an
object
the book became rather famous rightly
but he followed it up in 1827 with a far
less well-known publication a memoir on
the temperature of the earth and
planetary spaces in which he puzzled
over the average temperature of the
earth you see if you apply for Rio's
maths and some other basic
thermodynamics to the Earth you come up
with a startling conclusion
you can estimate the average temperature
of an object in space like a planet by
balancing the energy coming in from the
Sun in the form of sunlight with the
energy leaving the object due to what we
call thermal radiation the hotter an
object is the more energy it kicks out
into space as this radiation there will
be a temperature where the object is
just hot enough to emit the same energy
as it receives from the Sun what we call
its equilibrium temperature doing the
maths you find the Earth's equilibrium
temperature is minus 16 degrees Celsius
well in fact the Earth has an average
temperature of about 15 degrees Celsius
Fourier had various theories about this
discrepancy but eventually decided that
the atmosphere must have some insulating
property not reducing energy arriving
from the Sun but preventing some thermal
radiation from leaving the Earth this
would mean the Earth would need to be
slightly warmer to give off enough
thermal energy to match that arriving
from the Sun maintaining radiative
balance he never found what this
insulating property was though his
obsession with Heat's life-giving
properties had him constantly wearing
multiple thick coats and the heating in
his Parisian apartment turned all the
way up until one day in 1830 Delirious
from overheating he tripped and fell
down the stairs dying a few days later
heat in the end killed him
as you've probably guessed the
insulating property Fourier was looking
for was provided by carbon dioxide
something that was first realized just
two decades later by a scientist in
Connecticut Eunice Newton Foote was a
remarkable figure in the history of
science raised in New York in the first
half of the 19th century she became
engaged with the pressing issues of the
day including campaigning for the
abolition of slavery and for the rights
of women to vote but she was also an
inventor she invented a paper-making
machine a thermostatically controlled
cooking stove and less squeaky shoes and
she was a scientist but of course she
was those things in a society in which
to be a woman was to be excluded while
she was an inventor her inventions were
patented in her husband's name as women
couldn't defend patents in court while
she was a very capable scientist it was
all but impossible to gain a research
position at a university in fact she was
extraordinarily lucky to be able to take
any college-level science classes at all
so when she published
circumstances affecting the heat of the
sun's rays in the American Journal of
Science and Arts in 1856 it was the
first ever publication by a female
author in any scientific journal other
than those dedicated to astronomy
Epoch shifting but for more than one
reason
her paper she detailed experiments she
conducted with different asses trapped
inside glass cylinders and heated by the
sun she noted that when she filled a
cylinder with carbonic acid gas carbon
dioxide it was heated to a higher
temperature by sunlight and crucially
retained its heat much longer than those
cylinders filled with other gases she
correctly identified fourier's heat
trapping property of the atmosphere
carbon dioxide didn't obscure sunlight
but it absorbed thermal radiation and by
being present in the atmosphere even in
very modest quantities this increased
the average temperature of the Earth
chances are though that you've not been
told about foot discovering that CO2
traps heat and how she explicitly stated
this warmed the Earth this discovery was
instead for the longest time attributed
to the Irish physicist John Tindall who
seemingly independently recovered the
same result with a little more detail in
1861 though there's some debate about
this because Tyndall had quote little
regard for women's intellectual
capability and so may have just stolen
her work and not bothered citing her
Tyndall was much more famous and male
than foot but making matters worse
foot's work was mostly lost in a fire at
the Smithsonian Institute in 1865. so
she was forgotten for most of subsequent
history her results were only
rediscovered in 2011. so while you may
have heard of Tyndall foot was actually
the first person despite many obstacles
to discover that CO2 kept the Earth
warmer than it otherwise would be
however this graph shows the average CO2
concentration in the atmosphere in a
given year as you can see it's not
constant it fluctuates year to year
insulating the planet by slightly
different amounts and according to the
theory established by Fourier and foot
causing its average temperature to
change
it was also around now that scientists
were for the first time learning about
how the average temperature of the
planet had changed significantly in the
Deep past people like Louis Agassi and
other people who didn't steal their
ideas were describing ice ages periods
where the Northern Hemisphere was much
colder than present for prolonged
periods and so the Earth's average
temperature was significantly lower the
prevailing View at the time was that the
Earth was still cooling down from its
red hot creation so how they asked could
it have cooled and then warmed again to
present day temperatures some people
including foot advocated that changes in
CO2 were responsible more CO2 in the
atmosphere went a warmer Earth while
bless CO2 meant a colder Earth another
person who thought this was Swedish
chemist svante Arenas a child prodigy in
his day job he basically founded what we
now call physical chemistry and for this
work won the 1903 Nobel Prize in
chemistry but he had diverse interests
in including climate in the 1890s Arenas
wondered what temperature change would
take place if for some reason the
concentration of carbon dioxide in the
Earth's atmosphere halved this was 1896
and long before this question could be
answered fully with calculations
performed by digital computers but
Arenas did have one advantage on his
side
getting divorced
two years previously he had married his
student Sophia rudbeck side note you
and the marriage had not gone well they
were separating messily Arenas wanted
something anything to take his mind off
things so he threw himself into the
painstaking time-consuming pencil and
paper calculations approximating how
different latitudes would respond to
changes in atmospheric CO2 and
eventually concluded that the Earth
would cool on average by 5 degrees
Celsius enough through various feedback
loops to trigger a new Ice Age this was
an impressive feat but his colleague
Arvid hugbum wanted something what if
instead of halving CO2 concentrations
you doubled them hugbum had compiled
estimates of how carbon was cycled
through natural geochemical processes
emitted by volcanoes and absorbed by the
oceans and so on doing this had given
him a curious thought what about
estimating how much carbon humans were
putting into the atmosphere too after
all most fuels used by humans are
hydrocarbons structures containing both
hydrogen and carbon most notably wood
oil and coal when you burn these things
the combustion reaction releases the
carbon previously trapped in the fuel as
carbon dioxide gas into the air if that
fuel came from deep within the ground
such as I don't know coal then you're
adding new carbon to the atmosphere
humans have been burning fuel and
putting carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere for thousands of years but on
a relatively small scale and not
typically using those fossil fuels from
deep within the Earth the 18th and 19th
centuries however saw an explosion of
fuel usage notably coal being burned to
power steam engines after their
invention by Thomas newcomen and
refinement by another Resident of
Glasgow and contemporary of Joseph black
the discoverer of carbon dioxide James
Watt by the time hugbum and arenius were
conducting their research engines
descended from those designed by what
were powering steamships factories power
plants and locomotives all over Europe
and the Americas visibly altering the
local atmosphere with smog but all those
factories and Industrial machines
burning coal might add up to something
significant on a global scale too hugbum
thought after years of analysis he
estimated that humans were adding enough
carbon to the atmosphere each year to
raise its concentration by one tenth of
a percent he mentioned this to Arenas
and suggested that maybe in the distant
future humans could double the amount of
CO2 in the Earth's atmosphere at
hugbum's suggestion then arenius
repeated his thermal calculations for an
Earth with twice as much CO2 and found
that the planet would be five or six
degrees Celsius warmer again feedback
loops were at play here a warmer Planet
meant more water evaporating into the
atmosphere leading to a more insulated
Planet leading to a warmer planet and
and so on he considered this to be a
good thing it would Stave off another
Ice Age but also that this was a
hypothetical something that wouldn't
happen for thousands of years humans
just weren't burning that much fuel
abstract as they were his ideas were not
taken especially seriously by the
academic Community Arenas was seen as
something of a kook with interests that
ranged too broadly to be at all deep
outside of his specialism in particular
the scientific Community was dismissive
of the idea that human emissions of
carbon dioxide could accumulate in the
atmosphere after all if you leave carbon
dioxide and water together they
eventually form carbonic acid so with
the huge surface area of the world's
oceans and the relatively tiny
concentration of CO2 in the atmosphere
seawater would almost certainly absorb
any extra anthropogenic carbon quite
quickly
just 10 years later though Popular
Mechanics was reporting a general sense
that Winters were warmer than they used
to be scientists were warning that
European glaciers were melting due to
raised temperatures in 1923
meteorologist Heinrich Von ficker went
one step further and warned that a trail
of climatic change was occurring from
the steps of Asia to Central Europe
bringing drought and decreased
agricultural yields as a result of some
Global climatic shift was extra carbon
in the atmosphere responsible for this
some thought so arenius's ideas were
Revisited in the 1930s by British
scientist guy calendar in 1938 he
published a paper titled the artificial
production of carbon dioxide and its
influence on temperature in it he
estimated that since the end of the 19th
century humans had added an incredible
150
000 million tons of CO2 to the
atmosphere and that this was beyond what
the oceans could absorb so three
quarters of the CO2 emitted by humans
was still in the atmosphere this
calendar estimated had won the planet by
a third of a degree Celsius
however just like arenius calendar
believed this was a good thing it would
Stave off the quote Return of the deadly
glaciers
scientists have lost a bit of Panache
since then I guess maybe future
Generations would thank us for warming
the planet and preventing another Ice
Age however also like iranius calendar
wasn't a specialist in physical climate
instead researching Steam for his day
job and so he wasn't taken especially
seriously people still thought that the
oceans were easily capable of absorbing
any carbon dioxide that humans emitted
while these emissions were real they
weren't going to change the climate
calendar must be wrong but some
oceanographers were starting to question
that assumption oceanographers like the
giant Roger Ravel who we met at the
beginning Revel studied Oceanic uptake
of carbon dioxide for his PhD but
returned to the subject in the 1950s
with his colleague Hans Seuss motivated
by newly invented carbon dating
techniques they re-examined that
all-important rate at which oceans
absorb carbon and found that a typical
molecule of carbon dioxide emitted into
the atmosphere would be absorbed by the
oceans in a decade or so no reason to
worry the oceans would effectively wash
away all our emissions before they built
up to anything significant
but then Ravel remembered something from
the chemistry he studied in his PhD sea
water does something called buffering
it's a chemical process that stops the
ocean's acidity from rising too much
while seawater might initially absorb a
lot of carbon creating a lot of carbonic
acid eventually buffering will spit much
of that carbon back out into the
atmosphere no one had considered this
process in the context of carbon dioxide
emissions before so Revel went back over
his calculations and found that in some
accounting for that eventual spitting
out of carbon the ocean's ability to
absorb carbon dioxide had been
overestimated
by a factor of nine as an historical
aside Ravel realizing that this
buffering mechanism was relevant was a
super late addition to the paper he was
submitting on the oceanic uptake of
carbon so late that it wasn't included
in the typed up manuscript it was
hastily taped to the manuscript with a
note
revela had found that there was a very
real possibility that counter and Arenas
were onto something and that carbon
might be building up in the atmosphere
to find out if this was really taking
place he needed data and in 1957 he got
his wish the international geophysical
year it was a collaboration between
scientists all over the world
researching everything from space to the
Antarctic to the bottom of the oceans
much of it motivated by the Cold War and
the Americans and Soviets wanting to get
a military advantage over one another
Ravel was a key figure on the American
side of things and was able to secure
modest funding for the academic
Backwater of climate science he put this
money into action measuring carbon
dioxide concentrations over the year
with extremely high Precision to
accomplish this he hired a young postdoc
named Charles David Keeling
Keeling was a fascinating guy who turned
up at exactly the right time in history
Ravel would later say of Keeling that he
was a peculiar guy he wants to measure
CO2 in his belly and he wants to measure
it with the greatest precision and the
greatest accuracy he possibly can the
benefit of hindsight thank goodness he
turned up when he did
using expensive new instruments that
allowed for unprecedented accuracy and
with a single-minded determination to
root out any and all errors Keeling
produced a beautiful data set of
atmospheric CO2 concentrations from
Antarctica and Hawaii in 1958. Ravel had
planned for that to be that this was to
be a baseline data set and someone could
take another set of readings in a few
decades to determine if CO2
concentrations had in fact changed but
Keeling had other ideas
he wanted to keep going he scrounged
together enough money to keep taking
measurements initially in both
Antarctica and Hawaii but eventually
just at Mauna Loa in Hawaii it became
clear after just two years that the
concentration of CO2 in the atmosphere
was indeed increasing year on year
Keeling initially published this result
in May 1960 and it was even covered by
the New York Times but people including
Keeling still weren't worried by this
Keeling himself thought that air
pollution was a bigger problem than
increasing carbon dioxide concentrations
but advised that we should keep
collecting observations in case the rate
of increase accelerated so he kept
taking measurements scrounging together
money wherever he could he kept
measuring the atmospheric CO2
concentration through the 1960s all the
while signs that the climate was
changing started springing up more crop
failures this time in India and the
Soviet Union people in the global self
Mauritania Mali and Chad noticed
persistent changes in weather more
floods but also more droughts the CIA in
a report in 1974 would say in retrospect
that the headlines from around the world
told a story still not fully understood
or one we don't want to face but that
the climate change began in 1960. the
line now known as the Keeling curve kept
going up carbon was clearly accumulating
in the atmosphere this by the way was
the data that Ravel shared with his
students at Harvard including a young Al
Gore who would go on to become a senator
and secure further funding for keeling's
observations during the tumultuous years
of the Reagan Administration
going into the 1970s as the world
population grew and grew more
industrialized and urbanized the
quantity of fossil fuels burned every
year grew and grew the engines
originally designed by what were
observably changing the atmosphere and
changing it faster and faster but was
this resulting in a change in the global
climate the weather might be weird and
crops might be failing but was the world
on average actually warming as calendar
thought
initially the answer seemed to be no
ever since the discovery of past ice
ages scientists were concerned that the
freezing conditions might return as more
about past climate was learned through
reconstructions based on Ice cores and
ocean sediments scientists in the
mid-20th century predicted that the
natural variability of the planet would
make it cool down for the next twenty
thousand years or so this would probably
be slow but there was the possibility of
rapid cooling over a millennia or even
centuries back to glaciated conditions
so when Global temperature data sets
were constructed in the 1960s and 70s
that showed some cooling over recent
decades for some the alarm Bell started
to ring the planet was Cooling and
tipping into a new Ice Age already not
warming as some scientists claimed
however two scientists from New Zealand
Michael Salinger and JM Gunn published a
paper in 1975 that pointed out these
data sets were dominated by data from
the Northern Hemisphere where most of
the scientists were the Northern
Hemisphere may be cooling but the
southern hemisphere according to their
work was in fact warming and had been
consistently since the start of the
century that was significant because
emitting CO2 is only one consequence of
burning fuel the combustion reaction
isn't perfect and so as well as carbon
dioxide unburnt bits of fuel and other
compounds like sulfur dioxide are also
emitted into the atmosphere and while
carbon dioxide traps thermal radiation
and so warms the planet those other
compounds can have the opposite effect
reflecting sunlight away from the earth
and cooling it down
but not just that because while CO2 is
mixed very evenly through the atmosphere
on account of being heavier those extra
combustion products tend to stick close
to where the fuel was burned scientists
like Wallace Brooker and James Hansen
argued that in the northern hemisphere
the cooling effects of those extra
combustion products were outweighing the
warming effect of the extra CO2 hence
cooling as fuel use exploded post-world
War II meanwhile in the southern
hemisphere with far far fewer people and
so far far less fuel being burned there
was basically nothing to mask the
warming signal of the globally
distributed carbon dioxide in the
scientific literature throughout the
1970s then there was this debate about
which effects warming or cooling would
win out on a global scale in the end
where we heading for a scorching future
or a snowball Earth this seeming
confusion and Division in the scientific
ranks was for some evidence that climate
science didn't know what it was talking
about and that the so-called global
warming effect was based on bunk science
but it's worth noting that at no point
in the 1970s that those arguing for
human-caused cooling constitute shoot in
the majority global warming was by far
the consensus opinion and by the 1980s
those arguing for net global cooling had
changed their stance in light of
overwhelming evidence
thanks to legislation like the U.S Clean
Air Act of 1970 Northern Hemisphere
Skies gradually cleared of sulfur
dioxide and other pollutants with their
cooling effect removed the temperature
Trends started moving in One Direction
upwards in some places the evidence was
inarguable but it would would take some
time for enough data to be collected and
analyzed for a judgment on global
temperature change to be made that would
be done by several research groups
independently perhaps most importantly
James Hansen and his influential
research group reported in 1980 that the
global average temperature had as a
result of combustion products and some
natural variability reached a minimum in
the 1960s and had since by 1980 this is
increased by 0.2 degrees Celsius further
while this temperature rise was within
natural variability and so swamped by
other signals they predicted
unprecedented warming was on the way it
would be clear as day unmistakably
human-caused global warming by the year
2000 and of course they would be proved
right
by the end of the 1970s then and
certainly by the end of the 1980s the
scientific Community was in agreement on
the physics humans burning fossil fuels
were raising the concentration of carbon
dioxide in the atmosphere and this was
increasing the average temperature of
the earth while the warming was very
modest at the time it would be
significant within a few decades and
spells serious trouble
Society was cottoning on to the danger
the first U.S president to publicly
mention climate change was President
Johnson in 1965. the UN the CIA fossil
fuel companies and environmental groups
were all discussing what to do about a
warming Earth throughout the 1960s 70s
and 80s so why did it take until the
mid-2000s and An Inconvenient Truth for
climate change to become an issue for
the electorate and something spoken
about in the mainstream
well that's a story of the 70s 80s and
90s and it heavily involves Gore
handsome and a cast we've yet to meet
let me know if you'd like to hear it
another time but to finish this story
let me take you back to the very
beginning and James Watt
human emissions of carbon dioxide
started to modify our planet's climate
with watts refinement of the steam
engine the energy his inventions
unlocked for use in mining industry and
transport created the modern world and
as a result he was somewhat ideated
after his death becoming canonized as
the saint of the Industrial Revolution
the man who built the modern world and
of course the modern atmosphere
commemorating his contributions to
society multiple statues were
commissioned of what including one for
Westminster Abbey in London that was so
improbably vast that when it was pulled
into the building it fell through the
floor destroying several rows of ancient
gilded coffins in the Crypt below we
have made the modern world
now we have to deal with the
consequences and the damage we have done
with Watts Legacy
of climate change is a story of physics
chemistry and the statistics the
building blocks of a huge scientific
Tower normally you would learn these
building blocks through Reading
textbooks and wrote repetition but this
isn't the most effective way to learn
that would be through being Guided by an
expert through new interesting Concepts
trying your hand and applying them and
developing your knowledge bit by bit
through more and more complex
interactive exercises an approach
suitable for those in full-time
education similar actually to my
experience at Oxford and those in adult
professional life well that just so
happens to be how brilliant works and
they have kindly sponsored this video
brilliant is an educational website and
app built on the concept of interactive
exercises across subjects in maths
science and computer science this video
Drew on Concepts from their courses in
chemistry waves and light and solar
energy and I created the graphs using
Concepts in their course on python I've
worked with brilliant as a sponsor
longer than any other and the reason for
that is I think their courses are
phenomenal I wish brilliant had existed
when I was learning this stuff in school
and University and if you are in
full-time education I would implore you
to check it out learning in this way
adds a whole extra angle on scientific
subjects and helps you understand them
faster and more fully of course if
you're not in full-time education then
you can use their courses to keep your
learning and problem solving skills
sharp as well as satisfying your
intellectual curiosity by diving into a
subject you've always wanted to learn
more about or of course a subscription
would be a great present for any student
in your life to get one head to
brilliant.org Simon Clark where you can
sign up for free and if you would like
to get a premium subscription then the
first 200 people to go to that link will
get 20 off thank you so much to
brilliant for continuing to support this
Channel and for sponsoring this video
thank you for watching the presentation
of this video was greatly inspired by
the work of Bobby broccoli one of the
best channels on YouTube please go check
them out if you've never heard of them
their videos on the history of physics
are fantastic the content of the video
was largely sourced from two books the
discovery of global warming by Spencer R
Witt and our biggest experiment by Alice
Bell as well as research conducted for
my own book ferment links to all those
will be in the description if you
enjoyed this and would like me to tell
the next part of the story please do let
me know in the comments please also like
the video and share it with others you
think will find it interesting it really
helps the channel out and helps this
important history spread further that
just leads me to say thank you again for
watching and I'll see you in the next
one